розмова футболістів у роздягальні хассі
п'єр провини дико з іншого бундесліга
пояснюючи сирійців мухаммаду аль-хусейн у
зовсім на футбольну тактику, а шлях я
кальвін голий у тебе анголи ціле шоу
нас 11 зустрічай професійних
футболістів з біженцями в
кінематографічному проекті команда
біженців презентація кого вигляд був ася в
берліні
f11 пруфе 11 amatory у 11 тому контексті
біженців товар на неї ми почав і гармат
футболі лізі ізі брала свою команду
nevian субота чого до розмова має рацію так
та проблеми біженців чемпіонка свята
лера промені промо за труднощі вода ти
пишеш про за грози депортації проблем
язик і мені довелося і заткнуся а син
profia сім'ї за рахунок і рабів проґав а
то я навчаю англійською в дамаск у акули
завершена в чані обіцяні їх там за
конем нашому син бути їжу армії
славний game принцип кіно проекту біжи
знайти профі розбавляють наливних
залиштеся зустрічався з screamin' a
team of кафе навику колоду мінімалка ніж
і звуками c був біль віджимання там та
затьмаримо стадіон ми не знімала на стадіоні
обидва в ексклюзивних здібностях ми намазалися
вона виїжджає і храми сильних футболістів
в дуб і російський спортсмен і мед
шанс у собі дружин зіграю ту клубу місця
ера в штат біткойному всю команду сир
цьому заснула у клубну наявність району
або ти їй складе 40гр after'll з 15
околиць йому 100 ми зрубали по передній
вербер ви означало кандидата для інтерв'ю
на сам парад через можна проблема афінах
починають 6-річна 11 короткометражних
фільмів виставляти в інтернеті про 11
біженців до 11 ох відомих футболістів
столітті коли з булл і бізнесу
[музика]